BELITTLING THE POINT HERE. I
REACHED OUT TO SOME FRIENDS.
ONE OF THEM BEING OUR NEXT
GUEST,
ACTOR, COMEDIAN HOST,
EXTRAORDINAIRE UTILITY, DH,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL. IT
IS A LITTLE DIFFICULT
BECAUSE HE IS A HUSKY.
BUT
AFTER HEARING
ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE AS A
HUSKY AND
WHAT THAT MEANS, I GIVE THEM A
LITTLE SLACK
IN ALL THIS. JOEL MCHALE JOINS
US NOW FROM HIS PLUSH
PALATIAL ESTATE HERE IN LOS
ANGELES.
GOOD MORNING, JOEL.
ARE YOU CAN YOU
GUYS HOLD ON? I'M TALKING TO
PEYTON MANNING.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING FOR HOURS.
NOTHING TO DO.
HE JUST WILL NOT. I MEAN ONCE
YOU GET THEM GOING THAT
MA'AM
TYPICAL PEYTON JUST WON'T STOP
TALKING. WHAT'S UP, BROTHER.
HOW YOU DOING THIS MORNING?
I AM WELL, WE HERE IN STUDIO
CITY,
AND IT'S SO GREAT TO BE
TALKING TO A COUG.
BECAUSE I ALWAYS LIKE TO TALK
TO THE
UNEDUCATED.
IT'S BEEN A PROBLEM FOR A LONG
TIME. YOU KNOW, IT TOOK ME A
WHILE. I GOT A GOOD.
I GOT, YOU KNOW, I WENT AND
GOT ONE OF THOSE HUSKY
EDUCATION'S WHEN I WAS IN
PRISON. SO IT WORKED OUT
BETTER FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS
INSTANT THAT GREAT
IT'S, IT'S HARD TO MAKE FUN OF
WAS ZU. Y FOR ALL OF YOU
LISTENING WASHINGTON. STATE
UNIVERSITY IS NOT THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON
EASTERN, WASHINGTON, EVERYONE,
THAT WAS LIKE, OH, IT'S STILL
IN WASHINGTON. IT'S EXACTLY
LIKE A DIFFERENT COUNTRY,
BUT
EASTERN WASHINGTON. NOW.
IS
PREME.
I MEAN, PRIMO WINE COUNTRY
NOW
AND WAS DO HAS THIS GREAT
WINE PROGRAM. SO IT'S VERY
HARD NOW TO JUST SAY YOU GUYS
ARE ALL JUST PARTYING AND
DON'T KNOW WHERE YOUR PARENTS
ARE BECAUSE YOU MAKE GREAT
WINE.
WELL, WE TOOK WHAT WE TOOK,
WHAT WE WERE BEST AT AND
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, DRINKING
AND TURNED IT INTO A REALLY
HONEST TO GOD PROFESSION FOR
A LOT OF GRADUATES THERE. SO,
YOU KNOW,
LEMON'S LEMON-AID TYPE OF
MENTALITY EXCEPT MAYBE GRAPES
WINE. THERE YOU GO.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THERE WOULD BE
KIDS, THAT WAS ZOO WITH
HUGE PLASTIC CUPS
GOING. GIVE ME SOME MORE
SAND GIOVES. A
IT. JUST THEY JUST NEVER
NEVER. I NEVER THOUGHT IT
WOULD HAPPEN. BUT BUT HERE WE
ARE
BLOOD. SO LET'S L REALLY TURN
THIS ALL AROUND YOU BLEDSOE,
WHO WAS,
YOU KNOW, THE QUARTERBACK
AHEAD OF ME AT WASHINGTON
STATE, YOU KNOW, WHEN HE GOT
OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF
FOOTBALL. HE GOT INTO THE WINE
BUSINESS
AND
THAT'S I THINK EVERYBODY'S
KIND OF TAKEN IN THE LEAD
FROM THAT AND FOLLOWED AND
FOLLOWED IN HIS FOOTSTEPS. SO,
VERY HE MAKES VERY GOOD
WINE. YES.
I'M SURE YOU SAW THAT ESPN
SPECIAL. I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WAS A
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY, BUT IT WAS
A SPECIAL ON HIM AND
IT'S SUCH A GREAT JOKE. HE WAS
SERVING WINE TO THE
INTERVIEW AND HE JUST SAID, IF
WE KEEP DRINKING, IT MIGHT
START TELLING THE TRUTH.
GREAT.
YEAH. HE DID THAT WITH
JEREMY SHAP. I THINK WITH
E60. I WAS A NEAT LITTLE
NEAT LITTLE PIECE.
LET ME, LET ME SAY EVERYONE,
IF YOU HAVEN'T LISTENED TO
RYAN'S PODCAST OR THE THING,
THAT THING YOU SENT ME.
GET IT. SO RIVETING AND SO
ENTERTAINING. AND
I WAS LISTENING TO IT WHILE I
WAS WORKING OUT AND I HAD
TO STOP WORKING OUT BECAUSE I
WAS SO
FREAKING
ENGAGED.
I APPRECIATE THAT. PAL, BY THE
WAY.
I WAS, I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW,
HOW DO YOU FEEL WHEN?
WHEN WHEN RANDOM FRIENDS?
I'M NOT GOING
TO?
SHARE WHO JUST RANDOMLY SEND,
YOU SCREEN SHOTS WHEN THEY
COME UPON A SHOW OR A MOVIE
THAT YOU ARE IN THAT THEY
ARE WATCHING.
WELL,
I AM LIKE A GOLDEN RETRIEVER.
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTENTION.
BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
I GOT INTO
THE ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS
BECAUSE I AM AN EXTREME
EXTROVERT
AND I KNOW IT'S REALLY COOL TO
BRAG ABOUT HOW INTROVERTED YOU
ARE, BUT I
RECEIVE ENERGY WHEN I'M AROUND
PEOPLE.
SO WHEN PEOPLE SEND ME THOSE
THINGS I GET
FOR THE MOST PART, I GET
EXCITED. IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW, I WASN'T,
I WAS LIKE
THAT WASN'T THE GREATEST. THEN
I'D BE LIKE, OKAY. WELL, MAYBE
THEY'LL COME ACROSS SOMETHING
THAT, I MEAN, THAT'S GOOD,
BUT FOR THE MOST PART, IT'S
I'M
DEFINITELY OKAY WITH IT. SO,
FRIENDS OUT THERE, JUST KEEP
SENDING IT.
AND THAT MEANS, I KNOW THAT
WHEN I GET LIKE A SCREEN SHOT
OFF OF
TELEVISION, THAT MEANS I'M
BEING PAID FOR THAT. I DO,
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
IT'S A GOOD POINT, BY THE WAY,
ALL, YOU KNOW, FULL
FULL
DISCLOSURE HERE,
I SENT HIM.
BUT I WAS WATCHING TED, THE
ORIGINAL, TED THE OTHER NIGHT,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
JOEL POPPED UP ON MY SCREEN
AND MY WIFE AND I ARE LOOKING
AT IT AND I
SCREENSHOTTED HIM IN ONE OF
THE BEST LINES OF THE
MOVIE, WAS HE HAD A PICTURE ON
THIS WALL WITH HIM AND TOM
SKERRITT AND HE JUST HE POINTS
AT OUT TO THE WAHLBERG'S
CHARACTERS. LIKE, THAT'S WHAT?
I'M SCARED.
YES,
BY THE WAY,
THAT'S, THAT'S A, THAT'S A
GREAT COMEDY.
THE LANCE ARMSTRONG TESTICLE
THAT I HAD. YES
CHARACTER HEAD.
LIKE DIPPING.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S GET INTO YOUR
SKIN TO YOUR HOMETOWN TEAM A
LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
OH EVERYTHING GREAT.
YES. I REALLY LOVE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SEAHAWKS,
BUT I WAS GOING TO SAY THE
KRAKEN,
THE
CREW, YA KNOW. I WAS GOING TO
SAY, IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE APPLE CUP,
BOY. IT WAS BATTLE
OF THE
INTERIM
COACH HAS, WHAT?
WHAT WHAT MAN THAT WAS THAT
WAS REALLY, IT WAS,
ITS, IT WAS
BOUND TO HAPPEN.
I DON'T, I DON'T TAKE A TON OF
PLEASURE. I CALLED THE GAME. I
WAS IN THE STADIUM THAT NIGHT
AT THE FIRST TIME. I'VE BEEN
BACK SINCE I WAS IN THE
STADIUM WHEN WE WANT IT IN
97, SO,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAD A TOUGH
YEAR. THEY HAD A REAL TOUGH
YEAR. THEY WENT ON GOT A GOOD
HEAD COACH.
I THINK I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO BE OKAY WITH WITH WHO THEY
GOT. WE'LL SEE HOW IT TURNS
OUT, BUT FOR AS FOR THE
APPLE CUP,
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
TEXTING YOU AND TRYING TO GET
US INTO SOME KIND OF
WE SHOWED A LITTLE BIT OF
WAGER OR SOME LIKE THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT A
BIG-TIME GRILLER AND
MEAT-EATER YOU ARE AS
OH, WAIT, RIGHT. WELL, LET'S
MAKE A
LET'S MAKE A DATE FOR NEXT
YEAR. I MEAN I'LL FORGET ABOUT
IT. BUT LET'S SAY
MATTER WHERE WE ARE.
LET'S TRY TO COOK SOME
LARGE DEAD PIECES OF MEAT
AND IRONICALLY ENOUGH. WE LIVE
LIKE FOUR BLOCKS FROM EACH
OTHER SO IT SHOULD BE PRETTY
EASY.
YEAH, BUT I' TURNED MY HOUSE
INTO A COMPOUND.
OH, I'M A CULT NOW. IT'S A
RELIGIOUS. YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO JOIN YOU
AGAIN YOUR ROPE. THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S OKAY. THAT'S LAST TWO
YEARS. I WANT TO BE A PART OF
SOMETHING ANYWAY.
PERFECT.
ALRIGHT. ALRIGHT, SO WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
SEAHAWKS. YEAH.
OKAY, SO
THEY WERE FAR FROM THE
PLAYOFFS, RIGHT? THEY HAD A
TOUGH YEAR.
HOW DO THEY GET BACK?
DO THEY CHANGE EVERYTHING?
OR DO THEY RIDE IT OUT?
THEY MADE A BIG CHANGE THIS
WEEK BY GETTING RID OF
KEN NORTON THEIR DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR, BUT EVERYBODY
POINTS AND TALKS ABOUT PETE,
CARROLL AND RUSSELL WILSON. I
DON'T THINK EITHER ARE GOING
ANYWHERE. I THINK THEY'RE BOTH
THERE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS THING
SHIFTS AND CHANGES IN?
CHANGES IN IS
II. JUST LOVE IT. WHEN THE
PANIC BUTTON, I MEAN, IT'S SO
I MEAN, SEATTLE SPORTS DOES
THIS? AND
I THINK EVERY MOST SPORTS, BUT
THEIR STUDENTS, LIKE,
RUSSELL, HAS HIS FINGER ALMOST
TORN OFF, RIGHT? SO HE'S OUT
FOR QUITE A BIT OF THIS
REGULAR SEASON,
AND WE DON'T DO THAT GREAT,
BUT
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
INSANELY GOOD PLAYERS. WE'VE,
I THINK WE'VE GOT ALL THE
PARTS BUT PEOPLE AUTOMATICALLY
GO. WELL, WE GOTTA GET RID OF
THESE PEOPLE,
AND I THINK THERE'S I THINK,
THEY, I THINK
PEOPLE LOVE TALK.
GOING. BUT
WE'VE ONLY MISSED THE PLAYOFFS
TWICE SINCE
PETE'S BEEN THERE.
HE'S A
TREMENDOUS LEADER, AS WE KNOW.
AND OBVIOUSLY RUSSELL IS
AN INCREDIBLY
SPECIAL
QUARTERBACK AND I
JUST DROVE. I'M LIKE, I KEEP
LOOKING AROUND
LIKE, WHAT THE PROBLEM, YOUR
GUYS, WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE,
AND WE ENDED THE SEASON.
VERY WELL,
SO I THINK
I'M NOT THAT. I'M NOT WORRIED
AND I THINK WITH A
HEALTHY RUSSELL
AND WITH A BETTER,
I MEAN WE ARE BUSY.
I HAVE SOME VERY GOOD
DEFENSIVE PLAY AND I THINK
WE'RE FINE. WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YEAH. I'M AGREEMENT WITH YOU.
I THINK THAT THIS
JUST ABOUT SHUFFLING SOME
PIECES AROUND. I DON'T THINK
IT'S ABOUT A WHOLESALE,
YOU KNOW, WRAP IT UP AND
TRY IT OVER AGAIN, TYPE OF
MENTALITY. YOU JUST CAN'T GET
RID OF,
YOU KNOW,
GENERATIONAL QUARTERBACKS GUYS
WHO'VE WON CHAMPIONSHIPS AND I
THINK FAN BASES, AND AND
MEDIA MEMBERS
TEND TO JUST JUMP ON SOMETHING
FOR THE IMMEDIATE SATISFACTION
OF WHAT IT IS. AND I THINK
THAT THAT REFLECTS OUR
WHOLE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE.
IN THIS COUNTRY. YEAH, SO IT
PLAYS OUT IN REAL TIME. AND
WHEN YOU'RE DOING A RADIO SHOW
LIKE THIS AND A TV SHOW. YEAH.
IT MAKES FOR A GREAT
FODDER AND AND, AND BIG-TIME
FUN. THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE
TALK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME.
THERE'S NOTHING I LIKE BETTER
THAN WATCHING THE
POSTGAME PRESS CONFERENCES AND
LISTENING TO
SPORTSWRITERS TRYING TO ASK
THE SAME QUESTION,
25 DIFFERENT WAYS
AND
I JUST DRIVE ME OUT OF MY
MIND AGAIN IF THIS
IS MY BIGGEST PROBLEM, THEN
I HAVE VERY GOOD
PROBLEMS. BUT
I YEAH, IT'S LIKE
YOU'RE SERVING A
WELL, I BURNED THE ROLE. SO
EVERYBODY GO HOME. YEAH,
LIKE WATCHED IT PLAY OUT THIS
WEEK WITH
THE LIKES OF
THE DALLAS COWBOYS, RIGHT?
MIKE MCCARTHY NEEDS TO GO, WE
LOOKED AT
KYLER MURRAY'S PERFORMANCE AND
KEITH COULD MUTE KLIFF
KINGSBURY PERFORMANCE ON
MONDAY NIGHT AND THEY'RE LIKE
THIS ARIZONA CARDINALS TEAM
IS, IS IN SHAMBLES AND NEEDS
TO GO FIRST TIME IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND FOREVER. AND
SO
IT'S JUST
REACTIONARY. I GET IT. WE GOT
TO TALK ABOUT IT. LUCKILY FOR
US.
WE HAVE SOME GREAT
GREAT NFL.
OFF GAMES THIS WEEKEND TO GET
US THROUGH THE
THROUGH ALL THAT.
YEAH. I AM NOT. I HATE
WHEN THIS.
LIKE THIS IS MY FAVORITE. ONE
OF MY FAVORITE WEEKENDS, THE
NEXT TWO WEEKENDS.
I HATE THE TIME OFF BEFORE THE
SUPER BOWL
AND SUPER BOWLS.
OBVIOUSLY VERY FUN. AND THEN
THERE'S JUST THAT LONG.
HARD
SPRING AND MOST OF THE SUMMER
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
FOOTBALL TO COME BACK AND
I
DO LIKE THIS NEXT THIS COMING
WEEKEND IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE. YEAH. IT'S DIVISIBLE
WEEKEND.
I'M A VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
OILERS.
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
THINK THE OILERS ARE,
IS THE OILERS ARE ONE TEAM. I
BEAT AS A STARTER IN THE NFL
SO I'M VERY YEAH, I'M VERY
HAPPY TO THEM AS WELL. VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE LA RAIDERS
AND THE ST. LOUIS RAMS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO ANYTHING
FOR SUPER BOWL? I MEAN, YOU
ARE
PRETTY MUCH DO EVERYTHING. ARE
YOU BEING ASKED TO DO ANYTHING
FOR THE SUPER BOWL SINCE IT'S
HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
ANGELES. WELL, IT
DID. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO DO
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
AND HAVE I
CAN'T
AGREE. I CAN'T BE IN.
GEORGIA WHERE I'M WORKING.
SO YES, IT KILLS ME
AND I WANTED TO PULL. LET THEM
KNOW. LET THEM KNOW THAT I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO FILL IN FOR
YOU BECAUSE I THINK, YOU KNOW,
YOU'LL TAKE MY KIDS TO THE
GAME. YEAH,
OF COURSE, I'LL TAKE A, YOU
KNOW, I GOT A FOUR-YEAR-OLD,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN WE CAN MAKE
IT WORK. I CAN I CAN DO THAT.
YEAH, IF YOU WANT TO TRUST HIM
WITH ME, THAT'S UP TO YOU, BUT
I'M MORE THAN WILLING. YEAH,
IF YOU'RE WORKING IT DOWN IN
GEORGIA. ARE YOU GOING TO THE
GAME?
I
HAVE TO GO SPEAK BEFORE THE
GAME AND I'VE NEVER,
I'VE NEVER STUCK AROUND FOR
THE GAME.
THE FACT THAT IT'S IN MY
HOMETOWN
THAT I'M LIVING IN AT THE
TIME,
IF I'M, IF I'M
GIVEN SOME SEATS WHERE THERE.
WHERE IT'S COMFORTABLE
SEATING, YOU KNOW, I MIGHT BE
UP TO IT. I JUST I HAVE A
WEIRD THING ABOUT WATCHING
FOOTBALL. I NEED TO BE LIKE
ALMOST
ALONE
IN
WITH A BIG TV SO I CAN JUST
SEE EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
AND AND REALLY
EMOTIONALLY.
OUT, WHEN THINGS ARE GOING
ON DURING THE GAME. IT'S JUST
BEEN A, THE WAY. I'VE
EXPERIENCED FOOTBALL, MY WHOLE
LIFE.
ALL RIGHT, SO IF YOU HAD YOUR
OWN LUXURY BOX
AND NO ONE ELSE WAS IN THERE
AND ALL THE LIGHTS WERE OFF
AND THERE WAS ONE MONITOR,
YOU'D BE FINE. I'D BE GOOD.
BUT I TELL YOU, RIGHT IF I'M
WILLING TO GET A LUXURY BOX
AND BE AROUND PEOPLE.
FOR THIS GAME. I'M
SAYING
EVERYBODY OUT THERE IF THEY'RE
ANYBODY'S WILLING TO GIVE ME A
LUXURY BOX FOR MY FAMILY
AND MY FRIENDS FOR THE SUPER
BOWL WERE WILLING, IT WILL
ACCEPT IT.
THEY SAY, IF YOU WERE JUST
SITTING IN THE REGULAR STANDS,
IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE ODD
THERE BECAUSE YOU WOULD JUST
BE APPROACHED BY
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME.
WE WENT TO, WE WENT TO A
CHARGERS GAME THE OTHER DAY
AND SAT IN IN SOME
SEATS DOWN THERE. AND YEAH,
WHEN WHEN, WHEN I WAS LEAVING,
IT GOT KIND OF, I THINK IT'S I
THINK, MORE OR LESS. ITS
IT WAS FOR.
THEY JUST WANT SOME PHOTOS,
YOU KNOW, AND I GET IT
I GET IT. BUT
HEY BUDDY, ARE YOU A PHOTO
TAKER OR DO
YOU GIVE THEM THE
MENTOR, DO YOU LIKE? I'M A
PHOTO DECKER. I'LL DO IT. I
FEEL LIKE IT'S HUMBLING. IT'S
HUMBLING.
I DON'T KNOW. I'M NOT AS
RECOGNIZABLE. AS THAT'S A YOU.
AND
IT HASN'T IT HASN'T LOST ITS
LUSTER YET.
I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
HUMBLING
TO BE ASKED TO HAVE A PICTURE
WITH ME NOW. I AGREE.
YOU'RE NOT AS RECOGNIZABLE,
IT'S STILL COOL.
IT'S JUST HUGE. THEY JUST DO
THAT. AND I DON'T REALIZE HOW
BIG I AM UNTIL I SEE THOSE
PICTURES.
PICTURES. ALL RIGHT, MAN.
WE'RE UP AGAINST IT HERE. I
WANTED TO THANK YOU PERSONALLY
FOR FOR AGREEING TO DO THIS.
YOU'RE THE BEST. YOU'VE BEEN A
GOOD FRIEND HERE
TO ME IN LOS ANGELES, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME. HOW ABOUT A WONDERFUL?
WONDERFUL NEW YEAR
AND
AND TAKE CARE OF THAT FAMILY.
WELL, YOU'RE VERY
NICE. LISTEN TO RYAN
PODCAST YOU GUYS IT'S AMAZING
AND HE'S THE NICEST.
AND ONE OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
THAT HAVE EVER COME OUT OF
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY,
WHICH IS SAYING ALMOST
NOTHING,
HE TRIES HIS BEST
EVERYBODY JOE.
GAIL,
THANK YOU GUYS. THANK YOU. HEY
JOEL,
GO HUSKIES.
HE HAD TO THROW THAT IN THERE
AT THE END, A LITTLE
RUSSELL WILSON, AVE.
WEST TULSA MALIK. GO HAWKS.
YEAH,